i i'm very curious if someone has
actually never seen anything that you've
done before what is the first thing you
want them watching and why huh
that's a great question
um
i guess the professional's the best
place to start since it was the
beginning of anything i ever did when
did you realize that you being mighty
thor in this movie meant so much to so
many people it's it's
it's been really really moving and it
was really moving i mean i think
um every time i feel the passion of of
the fans whether it's at comic-con or
whether it's
at a premiere it's always um incredibly
moving and exciting to see how how much
it means in people's lives and last
night um
there were some women who were dressed
up in character at the premiere who were
telling me that they had like when they
were four years old been really attached
to padme and star wars and that like
this was so
like such a kind of like full circle
moment for them so that was really wild
to like
see people who had like kind of
grown up with me um now as like adults
and and and you know still being like
part of part of each other's lives um i
heard that this film had a few deleted
scenes was there anything that you were
really sad to see go
so much so much i mean that's the joy
and the the sorrow of a taika or td
project is that he creates so much
brilliance and so much
material that the movie could be like
an infinite
number of things and
it like inevitably means that incredible
hilarious
moving comedy and drama
ends up not there so there's a lot
there's a lot there's i mean there's
full
planets that are not there anymore
i i'm gonna have to beg tyka to release
a whole bunch of this stuff i pray that
it'll end up in like dvd extra somewhere
or that it comes comes out somewhere
because i mean yeah it's it's pretty
remarkable stuff one of the things i
love about taika is that it's literally
his imagination on screen it it's wild
there's things that i never expect to
see that that are in the movie well it's
like one or two things that you were
like oh my god i cannot wait for people
to see this
um
i don't want to spoil anything but um i
think
we know that there's a kind of
world of gods right i think that's been
in some of the trailers um and so some
of the gods
i'm sure you know which ones
one in particular was
hilarious to me i lost my mind seriously
um with the goats and especially and i
don't want to say anything but the audio
with the goats it's so good right so
good what was your reaction what is it
like actually because a lot of this is
vfx what is it like for you to actually
finally see the finished film it's
incredible um to see i mean i think
that's part of what is such a
like just eye opening when you see the
finished version is how many incredible
artists work on it after what we do to
create what actually the audience
experiences because i mean most of what
you see is you know affects artists um
but funnily enough the goats we had real
goats like real
practical they weren't actual animal
goats they were you know practical kind
of sculptures that we had on set with us
with like tongues out and everything uh
i i think i have to rap i'm just going
to say i really do hope tyco releases uh
some of the deleted scenes please pass
that on yes yes me too i i i feel the
same on that note congrats on the movie
thank you good seeing you